ha già detto
gabriella vendi non so più che a
raccontarvi ok
oggi si parla di futuro ma io partire
con una storia del passato con un 28 6
questo è stato il mio primo computer che
mi fu regalato quando avevo solo sei
anni dice va bene ti potevano regalare
una bicicletta una macchina
telecomandata con altri gli altri e
all'epoca in effetti con un computer non
si facevano cose proprio esilaranti
la cosa bella però è stato il fatto che
il computer era mio ci potevo fare tutto
quello che volevo e fatti ci faceva un
sacco di danni ho continuato a fare
danni anche in età più avanzata più
adulta quando poi mi sono appassionato
ovviamente l'informatica e sono
diventato uno sviluppatore quindi
diciamo con un'infanzia così difficile
poter immaginare quando scoperto goder
dojo cover doge un network
internazionale di volontari che
insegnano gratuitamente a programmare ai
bambini in tutto il mondo
ho subito capito il loro piano diabolico
li vogliono li vogliono subito prendere
adesso che sono piccoli a farli
appassionare prima che capiscano che nel
mondo c'è anche altro
no in realtà ho subito manifestato
interesse di partecipare di intrufolarmi
e sono andato due anni fa al uno dei
primi eventi dico del doge milano
la cosa che erano erano appena partiti e
la cosa che più mi ha colpito è stato il
caos creativo c'erano bambini di ogni
età dai 6 fino ai 13 anni e soprattutto
anche diciamo i mentor avevano
esperienze diverse dagli sviluppatori
professionisti fino a educatori o
persone semplicemente i genitori e
persone che volevano dare una mano
perché il bello di cover dojo e che si
insegna e si impara allo stesso tempo e
quindi non ci sono corsi per diventare
mento robolini certificazione bisogna
smanettare provare a giocare con i
bambini e imparare come si fa e in
effetti io li ho imparato il linguaggio
che all'università non mi avevano
insegnato
si chiama scratch nemmeno insegnato
oliver che un bambino di sei anni
insieme a lui mi sono mi sono messo
accanto a lui e osservare
come mettere insieme delle istruzioni
che in scratch sono rappresentati da
blocchetti come se fossero dei lego e
attraverso questi blocchetti le ho
costruito un suo primo videogame
ovviamente in coder dojo si insegna e si
impara quindi oltre ad avere imparato
scratch ho cercato di ricambiare
insegnando oliver come cliccare il tasto
destro visto che non ci arrivava con la
manina gli ho anche insegnato a
spostarlo a riportarlo indietro perché
ogni tanto in covered oggi scadono i
bambini stesi in questo modo i tavoli
ecco dopo dopo un paio di mesi sono
riuscito a riportare l'esperienza anche
a bologna grazie all'aiuto di amici e
mentor smanettoni che è tuttora c'è chi
mi aiutano in questo momento stanno
facendo un dojo proprio adesso al linux
day a bologna
oltre a fare insomma attività bologna mi
sono messo un po a girare i vari dojo
che allora erano soltanto tre o quattro
ma adesso sono diventati 40 in tutta
italia stanno continuando a crescere
guidato dalla curiosità di capire come
funzionavano come nelle singole realtà
coder dojo prendeva prendeva vita
appunto il bello è che cambia a seconda
del post però diciamo che c'è un tipico
dojo che
in cui sostanzialmente si fa un tutorial
iniziale utile a chi non ha mai
programmato
poi si fa merenda e nella seconda parte
che quella più importante è
tendenzialmente diventa sempre più lunga
è quella in cui i ragazzi decidono da
soli che progetto realizzare e sono
aiutati non solo dai mentor ma anche dai
compagni quindi si collabora applausi
della merenda io volevo raccontare una
storiella parte è un momento molto
importante quindi distacchiamo dai
computer ad esempio alla media fair poco
poco tempo fa un paio di settimane fa
cioè nei bambini che osservavano
osservando le mele in mezzo a un sacco
di gadget tecnologici arduini è così di
questo tipo è certo punto bambino
sapendo che le mele possono suonare
utilizzando alcuni dispositivi come i
mac i mei che si è avvicinato e ha fatto
ma questa me la cosa fa che questa è la
mela stampare in 3d e funziona benissimo
se mangi questa è stata la risposta dei
mentori in realtà dentro a covered oggi
si fanno tante cose questi sono alcuni
esempi di progetti realizzati da
entrando dentro al doge di bologna
abbiamo un batman realizzato fino al
terzo quarto il livello da luca di 14
anni
considero ed che ha fatto giulia
pochissimo tempo fa che ha chiamato
micio web
un po comunque una slide due gattini
serviva la useless box che è un progetto
che ha fatto google ha 17 anni e che ha
vinto il premio internazionale dei culex
project i progetti più più fighi del
d'europa e del mondo
e poi c'è il milk bot che è un robottino
il primo robottino parzialmente scremato
che è costruito con arduino all'interno
di una scatola di latte e questo l'ha
realizzato un bambino di 43 anni giacomo
che i nostri mento oltre a quello che si
fa l'importante è come lo si fa
ci spieghiamo a un dei prìncipi e
princìpi del creative learning che sono
sviluppati insieme a scratch dal dalle
menti in particolare da un gruppo di
ricerca del media lab che si chiama
lifelong kindergarten sono facilmente
riassumibili in quattro parole project
significa che si impara meglio quando ci
sporchiamo le mani e lavoriamo su un
progetto pierce sono i compagni cioè
impariamo meglio quando le informazioni
ci arrivano anche dai nostri stessi
compagni non per forza da un insegnante
per shaun fini che siamo guidati dalle
nostre passioni anche nella scelta dei
progetti
noi cerchiamo di dare l'opportunità ai
ragazzi di lavorare su qualcosa che per
loro conta veramente tipo i piattini di
giulia
e poi c'è il play che non significa
soltanto giocare e divertirsi ma
significa anche non avere paura di
sbagliare quindi sperimentare in
continuazione appunto senza senza timore
zac cosa c'entra tutto questo con il
futuro c'entra in diversi modi
innanzitutto c'entra con il fatto che
c'è sempre più bisogno di sviluppatori
questa è una statistica americana e so
che in europa i dati sono molto simili
c'è sempre più bisogno di sviluppatori e
si prevedono insomma quasi milioni
milioni di posti di lavoro che al tasso
corrente non potrebbero essere ricoperti
ma soprattutto poi c'è bisogno di
programmatori che siano anche socievoli
e creativi ecco questo è un valore
aggiunto che che non fa male visto che
si lavora sempre in gruppo
l'altro aspetto il fatto che noi
dipendiamo dalla tecnologia dipendiamo
dalla tecnologia sa che lì la usiamo
ormai per risolvere qualunque tipo di
problema come tenere ferme le porte ad
esempio il nostro il nostro scopo quello
che cerchiamo di fare attraverso i coder
dojo e cercare di trasformarli da utenti
passivi e quindi da ragazzi che sanno
usare benissimo le tecnologie ma
soltanto verra usarle in maniera passiva
quindi come ad esempio giocandoci a
super eroi perché quando i ragazzi
capiscono che anche loro possono creare
un videogioco un'animazione un biglietto
d'auguri attraverso il computer
programmando si sentono un po supereroi
e quello che facciamo e cercare di
trasferire gratuitamente il nostro super
potere a loro il terzo tema è ancora più
ampio riguarda l'imprevedibilità del
futuro
non sappiamo a quali sfide i ragazzi che
oggi i bambini bambini di oggi non
sappiamo che sfide dovranno affrontare e
proprio per questo ad esempio non
sappiamo che mestieri faranno in futuro
l'unico modo per aiutarli a fare in modo
che siano più bravi a imparare a
imparare continuamente ea non avere
paura di imparare
per questo mi piaceva concludere con una
frase è proprio di marco zamperini che è
proprio l'anno scorso due anni fa diceva
agli analfabeti del futuro non sono
quelli che non sanno leggere o scrivere
ma sono quelli che non saranno capaci di
imparare disimparare e imparare
grazie e grazie a tutti i mentori coder
dolce italia e del mondo che regalano ai
bambini la loro risorsa più importante
il tempo soprattutto quello del weekend
grazie